what's up everybody welcome back to led
live how would you respond if god told
you to make an
image of the beast find out on this
episode of
led live
light exposing darkness thanks everybody
for joining us for our this week's show
we have a special guest today we have
jason but before we get into that
we want to just tell you that we thank
you so much for our patreon donors
without you we cannot do this show
if you guys want to help sponsor this
show you can click the link below
become a patreon partner you get a lot
of cool behind the scenes footage
a cool t-shirt and just you get to meet
us personally and just see what we do
around here also we have dvds
and full-length documentaries that are
not on youtube you can get those on
vimeo for digital download and also we
have
stickers if you want to sticker up your
car or whatever
that's a good way to help support us and
also
to promote what we do also we have
t-shirts on our teespring store and
also at little lightstudios.tv you can
order those directly from us
it's a big help to us and also they're
just really cool ways of
sharing your witness we say we like to
say you can wear your witness with these
shirts
and now let's meet jason so i met jason
because
i ran across this video of a guy who who
created this big image of the statue of
nebuchadnezzar
it's a stat it's a prophecy in daniel
that tells all the kingdoms that
happened
and historically we can look back and
see that bible prophecy was fulfilled by
these kingdoms
and so i was just kind of looking into
who he knew
and stuff and ran across your page
because you helped design
some of the artwork for this and uh so i
just saw your channel and i was like man
i love this dude's artwork
all right here's uh the second set of
cards that we've been working on these
ones are called
kingdoms so these are based on daniel 2
and 8. the first kingdom that we see
is babylon head of gold daniel 2 also
referred
to as a lion in daniel 7.
and you were doing images from daniel in
revelation
and i was just like really intrigued by
it you want to bring out
the statue you have a little one right
oh the little daniel one yeah
yeah i mean we can show the daniel one
[Music]
little light studios presents a new
anime documentary oh i'm so excited
about it
coming soon what's coming soon tacos
no candy it's the documentary coming
soon
make sure you're following us on social
media so you know when it comes out
yay
[Laughter]
that was good
did you break it is it this one
so you have the one that's actually
realistic
this is a real practical illustration
because this is
no longer gonna stand
when that rock of jesus comes and
destroys that thing and he sets up his
kingdom
yeah just for anybody out there who
doesn't know about this it's it's not
really like um
scotty's little image or whatever this
is a
prophecy in daniel or nebuchadnezzar had
a dream about an image and he actually
forgot what the dream was but
daniel prayed to god and god revealed
the dream to him and told him what the
meaning was
and so all these medals actually
represent a kingdom
and when you look back in history you
can see that prophecy was indeed
fulfilled
and it's just a great way to show that
the bible is trustworthy and the
prophecies are true
if you want to know more about that we
actually have bible studies that's right
awesome uh we'll put the link in the
description below but i think it's
lls dot tv slash bible study
for bible school and we've actually seen
somebody going through those right
yeah actually several people have been
going through those awesome yeah we just
started that so that's a really cool
thing that we like to help people
because you can only cover so much on
this show and we want people to be able
to go
further in their studies so i know this
show is is supposed to get into um
jason's life and jason's testimony here
but i just have to say a second about
this
image that i first also saw you um
create the statue um hopefully we can uh
uh show some clips of this because it is
it is impressive i mean the the the
scale that you guys did and the the
massiveness of this thing oh it wasn't
it wasn't that size
no it wasn't the size oh yeah it wasn't
uh it wasn't a little how tall was it
uh i want to say 30 almost 40 feet
i can't remember is it two scale because
it yeah the real one was like 66
yeah right so that would be a a very
difficult thing to probably create but
nonetheless it takes a semi to move this
thing wow
and so impressive that when i saw it i
just went
wow this is a unique way to to witness
to people so i'm excited to hear what
you have to say so we we've been talking
for a little bit and then the other day
you just said hey he's still in
chatterjee again so
he came and he brought a giant beast
with him
and we'll show a picture of that but
it's uh the harlot riding the
seven-headed beast so
what is all this about man where i want
to know where
god has taken you through this journey
i'm curious to hear a little bit of your
testimony where you were
and how god's got you through that and
what he has you doing today
yeah um i uh
i i was born into a christian home my
parents were
missionaries we traveled all around um
but uh it got a little interesting when
i got around the age of
13 or 12 or whatever um
i saw hypocrisy happening in the church
i mean there's
hypocrisy in every church but um
it really disturbed me and uh i actually
became so angry because of it because i
saw someone get hurt so bad
and uh the person that hurt them got
away scot-free
you know and like and uh especially when
people stand up for those individuals
and they're
they say that they represent you know
their their christian and all this stuff
and when you see all that the people
that are
teaching you and leading in schools and
churches and stuff turn
um turn against the innocent you know
what i'm saying
yeah when i saw that i i became so
deeply disturbed by it i became so angry
at god
that uh i actually started turning to
the other side
and i started praying to satan and uh
a little raw but like i actually asked
told satan that if he helped me kill the
man
that that harmed that person i can't say
names or anything
like that he could have me
once i've once once he's helped me do
that
and so i knew the consequences i knew
all that but my anger was so intense
against that and i was so angry at god i
was like if there
you know i don't want nothing to do with
him
and uh so i started planning my
what i was going to do i decided when i
turned 18 this is when i was going to do
it
this is how i was going to do it so i
was planning it all out
um but as i was living that lifestyle of
just not caring
about life and about others or anything
i
as soon as drugs came my way i started
taking them
i started taking whatever started coming
my way and before i knew it
i was so entrenched with like getting
high
and just losing reality that that became
my all in all
and i started losing what it was like my
focus
and um before i knew it i started going
down a path
of of trying to find
i guess you would say the meaning of
life because once you start
playing with the devil your reality
really starts getting twisted
and the more you start going down those
those avenues of psychedelics
it just gets worse and worse to but
there was one experience as this was all
happening that
really i saw as a a turning point in my
life
um was my dad um
one day i was out of school and i had
already dropped out
and i was just i just got back from
getting high with my friends and it was
at a dormitory and i was hanging out
there
and my dad comes up my dad would never
come like come over to this dorm so he's
kind of odd and he comes up to me says
jason can i talk to you for a second and
i said yeah that's fine
so he pulled me aside and he says to me
um
he says jason i've been watching you for
a while now and i've
i've seen how you've been getting into
drugs and all these different things
he's like and i thought it was just
going to be a phase
so you know i just was going to let you
go through it and just you know
hopefully see you come out but he says
but i didn't
you weren't coming out and he says and i
just want to let you know
that i'm willing to help you if if
that's
if if you're uh if you allow me to
and when i saw that you know what i mean
this is the same dad that when i
walk home when i would come home heis a
kite just all maxed out on x
that i would walk into the house and i
would see my dad and we were my family
is going through a hard time
and here he is sitting there while his
whole family is just getting
just torn apart by the devil my eyes are
blitzed and i look into his face and i
know he knows i'm high
he just looks at me and he looks back
and he just keeps on doing what he's
doing
not one bit of anger not one bit
and when i saw that
that showed me a love not my i'm not
saying my dad's a perfect person
but it showed me god's love in him wow
you know what i mean caring for me even
though i didn't care about him
i didn't care about anybody and that
started changing my life i didn't give
up
you know i didn't give up everything but
i took his help
and he helped me move out of the area so
i was away from those friends
and after a while long time went on
and he helped me uh i was
i was getting a job up in canada and are
trying to go to school and whatnot
and um i still struggling with a bunch
of stuff
my dad gives me a call when i was up in
canada he sees jason
would you uh would you like to go out to
the marshall islands with us i said
are you kidding i just got i just got
this this um school thing and i got all
this got
like all this stuff's been opening up
and uh he goes well let's just put it to
a test
you know like let's ask god where he
wants you and he told me
jason have you been acing your tests and
i said yeah
because i was studying an anatomy and
physio or anatomy for um
to do spa masseuse or whatever
and uh and he says on your next test
if you get below 80 percent then that
means god wants you to come with us
i'm like i'm like i'm like yeah yeah
yeah and like
i i barely even believed that there was
a god at that time i was like yeah
yeah okay whatever and so i went and i
took the test i came home i i got the
results or whatever
and it was 78 percent and i'm sitting
and i'm just like are you kidding me
i've been acting all right
and yeah and it was all memorization so
it's just like index cards you just
going over all the muscles everything
and so i find out my friend calls me up
he's like hey man you uh
you had two index cards in my car you
lost them so it was those
two cars yeah and so
he uh i moved out to the marshall
islands i i got out so they took that as
a sign
oh i did yeah i i i was like this like i
i believe like i had faith in it like
you know what i mean like especially
coming from my dad yeah and so um i got
out to the marshall islands and i was
just like awesome man and like i i'm
like i
you know i'm going to try god out i'm
going to do this or whatever
and i get out there and i go to the
fridge
like because we just got into this house
and some someone was living there or
whatever and like
we're staying with him and i i opened
the fridge and there's a
case of beers there and i was like oh
sweet i'm like
i'm out in the ocean i got beers and we
go and i took it out to the beach
and i get out there and i open one i
start taking a drink and the
and the holy spirit goes i brought you
all the way out here
and this is what you're going back
because you had been
clean for a while yeah i like i i quit
drinking
when i left canada and i came over that
i just quit at cold turkey
and i was i was like okay there god
wants me here i'm gonna try and like
work this out
so while i was there i threw those beers
into the water and i was done
and i i went to god i said lord if
if you want me to follow you you need to
help me
to to read again because i'm so bad at
reading my mind is so
distorted and whatever that um and he
helped me
read and help me to understand and
that's where i started basing it i was
like
i'm like you know church is good and all
but i want to know for myself
i want to know you personally that's
where
i mean that's that's the story of how
god brought me to that
so you had mentioned something earlier
that i i think is a really good point
for
people to hear where was it when you
were like
it was your last experience with drugs
and your that was another kind of test
for god or if this was a way to find him
oh with the
like probably psychedelics and whatnot
because there are a lot of people that
believe
well you know these mushrooms god
created them and if you get this
experience you know it's it's just a way
for you to experience god and
and some people go as far as to say john
the revelator was yeah
when he wrote all that stuff like god
can give you a prophetic vision through
these psychedelics
but you probably had that in mind when
you did this so i think it's good for
people to hear that yeah the truth about
that i think it's always
interesting to me um the the the amount
of
dabbling into drugs that i did as well
it was very interesting if i think back
and i reflect on the people that i got
involved around the conversation always
goes to god
like have you ever noticed that yeah
like it does not matter if you're with a
ton of people that could like
literally care less you do a bunch of
drugs it's going to where god is
you know what i mean like and like it's
all distorted thoughts about it
you know weird stuff but why does it
always go to that
you know yeah yeah it's interesting
you're doing something you know they
call it spirits for a reason you know
i think you're opening up some kind of
doorway definitely and uh
it's not a good thing but i guess it
gets you thinking spiritually you know
well that's the perfect way for satan to
deceive you because now you think oh i'm
real spiritual but
but what you believe is truth is not
truth yeah
right so i'm gonna go on a limb here but
uh you guys haven't seen the matrix
or maybe you have but you don't even
know you don't even know the references
and stuff in there
but when he's talking about like you
know taking the red pill at the blue
pill or whatever like this and he's like
well
wait you know why am i taking these
things and he says it disrupts the
input output signal so that we can
pinpoint you
right meaning stopping the communication
and then they can have access to you and
i think that's exactly what the devil is
doing to us as well
i think that all these drugs are
literally getting in there and short
circuit
short-circuiting or communicating uh you
know stopping the communication
and then it's like the devil's got an
open door pouring water on a computer
oh yeah so i think there's a lot of
interesting points
out of this testimony one is you know
kind of going back to the beginning
obviously
churches aren't full of perfect people
right you can't look at the church
in fact there's there's kind of two
things one
you know um you know jesus said that
this is not a place for people who are
are well it's a place for people who are
need healing
and two if you look at all the seven
last churches or the seven churches in
revelation
they represent different time periods in
history the last one
god says is really the most messed up
people wise
it says they're wretched miserable poor
blind and naked you know they have a
terrible condition
and you shouldn't
go into the church especially in the
last days inspect that
you know especially god's church is
going to be full of these people who are
just
ready for translation you know right now
it's it's a
messed up group of people so yeah you're
gonna see things you're gonna hear
things
that very may very well may disturb you
um you know i think a lot of us are on
this
table have either left church
or wanted to leave church or
started to leave church because somebody
said something or because you've seen
something
and you know at the end of the day you
have to realize
you're not there because of those other
people
you're you're there for god you're there
to worship god and
yeah can you do that on your own yes but
he also asks you to meet with those
group of people
and it could be you know maybe we need
to flip the model on its head a little
bit
yes you're supposed to evangelize to the
world around you but you may be able to
minister to those people as well
right and help them in their situation
because obviously those people are
hurting
you know you go to church and you put
the the smile on your face people ask
you you know how are you
i'm fine everybody knows what fine means
you're not fine that's what it means you
know you just something to say because
somebody asked you
and you don't know what else to say and
you don't want to dump on them and say i
had a terrible day i yelled at my wife
on the way to church you know
i beat my kids or whatever you don't
want to tell people that
um i have had people say that to me at
your though you walk up i mean
you're used to like hey how's it going
how's it going i'm fine fine fine oh
pray for me i'm divorcing my wife
and then you're just like you know it's
like but at the same time it's like
at least you were honest yeah yeah you
know otherwise you know
and i'm not saying church is a place to
air all your dirty laundry
but you don't have to put on errors
either there's no reason for us to walk
around and be
you know more or less dishonest
so that was that was one really
interesting point and then
there was another thing um that you said
that i thought would that we
kind of needed to unwrap a little bit so
dad's reaction or something
no no it wasn't his dad's reaction i i
really appreciated the the
way that your parents reacted to it i
think that's really
an interesting thing because um
unconditional love man yeah you know i
mean your natural reaction is like
kid you're not what's wrong with you
and and for for for someone to lovingly
see you go through that and just sort of
like like
i'm just gonna be here for you anyway
and there's a picture of how i pictured
god we're doing all these things down
here that i mean just make him
cringe and he's not sitting up there
like smacking us around or whatever like
that
he's just he just gotta take it you know
and
when it comes to kids though like you
have to know your child
and if you have multiple even if you
just have one treat them as an
individual not a miniature version of
you or project anything onto them
so knowing when to give your child space
when when to know if it's a cry for help
and you should be loving on them
verbally physically whatever the case um
just knowing that
how to approach a child can make all the
difference in your life
i got one right now he's in those
teenage years he's 14.
and he is very much like my wife in a
lot of ways and so
him and her just like this you know he
and i get along great
but they butt heads which is which is
odd because
you know i really like her i really like
him
i know what it was though um i was going
to touch on the fact that you know here
you are
you start praying to the devil and
it's interesting people will
go down that road and they never really
get what they want
they think they give what they want but
they never really get what they want
and you didn't even like i'm guessing
you didn't even go through with
all of this other but satan was like
well you know you kind of give me
permission
so guess what you get hooked on drugs
you know it's like he got what he wanted
but you didn't get what you wanted and
that's why it always works with him
yeah because you know the more
the more he started leading me down
those dark roads
you know especially music wise you start
to see
how he worked in it and uh
because i would draw and i would sit
there in my room and it's just
a story of like my dad with us all is
like i would sit in my room at
like three in the morning and i would
have like i'd have black metal just
going
and i would just i could feel the
spirits enter into the room and you can
feel the power and i could i could
physically feel the power to draw and i
could draw better and i could
just be going and i would just be going
and like around three o'clock i
i turn it all off and i go to bed and uh
the the thing is my dad has always been
like he's always been such a godly
person in my life like even when i was
doing all this and whatnot every day he
told us
if as long as you're in my house you're
going to have worship and so every
morning at 7 we'd have worship every
evening
seven worship and so you know i
respected my dad
and like and i would go up and i would
sit and i'd have worship
and um i remember that day that one day
i
get up there and sit down and i look at
my dad and he just look
withered like i mean just like
distraught and i'm
just looking i'm like what on earth and
he goes he goes i don't know
what happened last night he goes but
at 3 am i was woken up and he said there
was something so evil in the house and
he's like i don't know what it was i've
been praying all night
and i was just like oh shoot i've been
bringing the demons into the home like
and it wasn't just like you know you can
feel something but yeah yeah but then
you realize you're putting your
family in jeopardy you know what i mean
from like
sad that's just wild experience i can
identify so much with your story dude
because it sounds so much like mine but
yeah like my parents would call my room
satan's layer and stuff same thing like
just metal music and i i realized some
of that stuff now
like back then i don't feel like i knew
what was going on like yeah i'm a demon
possessed or whatever but
i i could like freestyle on top of my
head i can't do that anymore
just play a guitar and words would just
come out and they'd rhyme and make sense
and stuff
and i can't do that anymore and it's not
anything like oh i wish i had that again
you know
yeah it wasn't glorifying god in any way
i wanted you to get back to
well before you move on to the next
topic then um i think it's just so
powerful that even in the midst of the
demonic presence that god's angels were
still there to prompt your dad hey wake
up you got to start praying i think
that's that's really powerful that god
god is there even though he may not be
able to reach you directly because he's
a gentleman he'll knock on the door and
wait till you let him in
but he's close he'll stay by you and do
everything he can
oh yeah and that's the thing is like i
i know that god never left my side
yep not because he would have
had to if it was based only on me
because i rejected him and i wanted
nothing to do with him but because of my
parents prayers
they they sent they sent those they
prayed on my behalf that the angels
would go you know and like if
i know for a fact like you what you're
saying like
he will give you a certain amount of
he'll just keep giving you candy you
know what i'm saying
but there's a place where he will seek
to devour you he'll get you in his snare
and then he'll kill you he's just like a
a spider you know get you in that web
and then he'll take care of you
and you know that's i saw it over and
over and over like i just couldn't
believe why am i not dead yet right
because i just didn't care if i die i
die you know what i mean
and i i remember like i mean i'm not a
bigger guy
and i remember like hanging out with my
buddy and we'd we'd just be doing x
together
and i mean like you know i remember that
night like trying to keep up with
everyone doing like
x and smoking and like what not and i
just remember i started passing out
and like passing on x is not a good
thing because you can go into
i don't know what it's called but like
but i just know that was not a good
thing and i just remember like
falling like falling and people like
shoving me like wake up man and like
and i just remember like that night
because we go all night long and like
i was like i should have died man like
it just like
i know my heart i already have an
enlarged heart and i can feel like the
palpitations all the time like going
through my ribs so like
with the ex on top of it but you know
god stands
god's so merciful even though i was
sitting there and i would just blaspheme
his name i didn't care
one ounce about him and i know satan
sought to destroy me i've heard so many
stories of men guys that went down that
path and satan destroyed them
yeah i mean he sees the beginning from
the end he sees
how he can use you in such big ways if
you'll allow him but
i think you know he could see no not
this one you're not going to get this
one saying i got big plans for him you
know he's going to
do what you're doing right now you know
using your art and your talent to reach
the world you know isn't that
interesting like why do we want to like
check out so much to the point where
we're like passing out and it's like
is this fun
are you having
[Applause]
you don't know the meaning of life or
anything you're not finding the answers
you just want to
forget like yeah just anything to get me
away from
thinking about reality or what this is
all about and so sad the beautiful thing
that god has given to us the
the just miracle in each breath that we
take and
and the daily life that we have and the
amount of people that you can
interact with and you know i mean when
you really live according to god's
principles how beautiful life actually
is
and you get to satan's level where he's
quote claiming that you can have all
this fun you can do whatever you want
you can do as much drugs as you want and
you get to the place where you're like i
don't care if i'm living
yeah like that's the lie that you buy
into
yeah well you know and like i i love the
story of the demoniac
you know and i think of i think of that
in the state of like i remember
psychedelics and i remember i don't know
having a bad trip to such a place where
you're so scared
you're never going to have reality again
you know that's something i would never
wish for someone but i
i'm i i'm thankful to have gone through
it so that i appreciate reality
so much more now like to be able to have
a mind to think
to have clarity like beforehand it's
just like nah i just want to get messed
up
but now it's like no way do i want to be
messed up like i actually want to eat
better
i want to sleep better i want to be able
to clear a thought
exactly and then you appreciate it so
much more you know it's like like jesus
says
those who have been forgiven much love
much those who have
gone down such horrible roads you know
when they find jesus when they've gone
down that dark path
they love the light they can't is like
i truly believe those that will be the
closest to the throne were those that
were the furthest from him
and that they truly love the lord so
much because of what he did yeah
i can only imagine being in heaven and
just walking around going i don't
deserve to be here yeah i deserve to be
here
you know this is amazing right and that
that is such a humbling
experience it's crazy it's literally all
about perception which is really
like this war against christ and satan
and satan is always
trying to warp our view of the world i
was editing um pride of life and you
brought up a jim carrey quote but then i
saw a different quote from him
and he said um i'm so serious about no
drugs
and no alcohol the world is too
beautiful for that
and i was like oh that's interesting
because he's seeing the world beautiful
and someone else could see that same
world as dark and depressing
and it's not until you lift that
covering from that person that
they'll do all they can to protect this
beaut this beauty that's all around them
yeah i often i've been sober for almost
eight years now but i often
uh describe it as needing glasses but
not realizing it
so all your life like no i don't need
glasses man i'm good to go
because every day you would just be like
living in this haze like
i'm just so used to being a little bit
drunk a little bit high
a little bit nauseous a little bit over
that
that becomes the new normal and you
don't realize it'd be like
me being like hey can you let me try
your glasses on just for fun of it and
it's like
oh there's actually individual blades of
grass it's not just
a green carpet like i can see so clearly
and so
that's where it's at you try to tell
somebody you don't know how much you'd
appreciate life if you were just sober
you don't know how much you're really
missing
no man this is life you know and then
when they finally go
two months sober it's just like dude i'm
totally seeing everything like yeah
this is the way it should be i can
memorize things like
you know i didn't even i used to not be
able to memorize numbers like phone
numbers and stuff and i'd catch myself
like
you know i'm reading or something i just
happen to glance at what page i'm on
or a verse i'm on or something the phone
rings and i
get on the phone and i get back why do i
remember i was reading romans 4 23 like
because i glanced at it that's something
i would have never remembered before
here's what's beautiful too though is is
i'm always
so shocked at how well god can reinstate
the mind
yeah how are you not walking around like
what's up brother
like people you've seen them they've
melted their minds
and then you see people who have like
transformed their life given their
hearts to god and it's like
they're straight as an arrow thinking
clear thoughts and
having you know very coherent
conversations
the bible says it will transform you and
renew your mind
that's right that's right quite
physically and literally he'll renew
your mind yeah
i i don't remember where i heard it but
i truly believe it
that the lord whatever he asks you to
give up
he's going to give you something better
in return and i mean i've seen it
over and over in everything from video
games to drugs
to everything that god had replaced
everything in my life
for something better you know what i
mean and wholesome
and real and you don't have to
like be ashamed of yeah i i often use
the illustration of of
wheat pancakes when i was a kid i just
love buttermilk
yeah the white the white just just cheap
wheat right
and like i remember going over to my
aunt's house and they'd serve like wheat
wheat pancakes or something because it'd
be like
what is this cardboard i'm not gonna eat
that right
and when i married my wife um she
transformed my taste buds
and now i actually prefer the healthier
the waffle or pancake the better and if
you set a white pancake in front of me
and that
i would choose the the hearty one over
every time
and and it's just a changing of the
taste buds and now the way that you
feel after doing that it's like way
better than the other way and so
i know if you give god a chance just
just the joy that you can experience
with him way out out paces
the the high that you get with the
ecstasy or whatever
and then the just drop down you feel
gross dirty you know like
yeah and and bad god is sustaining and
and this just like actual beautiful joy
yeah for sure
another thing about perception is that
it's not just
our outlook on the world and life it's
also we need to be mindful of other
people's perception of us
you know christ says we are the light of
the world we are little hymns
you know walking around and when people
see us they're supposed to see an image
of him
so going back to um you know a lot of
people's experience in church
when someone leaves and i've had i've
grown up in a church where multiple
people have left as well
there's this correlation like oh they
left church they left god and i realized
that's not really the case like the
person left the church they left
you you know what i mean they left the
madness that was happening there
and instead of shifting the blame like
the person blames god
no the person blames us like we messed
up within this church
what can we do to change that person's
perception or experience or love
to bring them back into the fold and to
really tighten their relationship not
just with us but with god
i think we need to really be mindful
about that what if somebody's like
you know what i'm going to go and try
ayahuasca man because i feel like i'm
searching i feel like i can find
god if i just go and meet this shaman
and do some ayahuasca or dmt because
i've heard a lot of stories about
people having these supernatural
experiences i've seen them you know
and uh but you had an interesting story
with that
yeah um well when i came back from the
marshall islands like you know i was
still working with god i was just
starting a relationship with him
and everything and uh i started asking
questions right because i'm like
all right i get it lsd it's man-made i
get it you know
cert these all these synthetics and all
these whatever that's all man-made
so tell me about mushrooms though tell
me about edibles
tell me about you know ayahuasca
dimensional tryptamine like certain
things you can
take out of a plant or whatever i'm like
you do the same thing with flour in a
you know sandwich or you know what i
mean like whatever like
why are these bad and are they bad and
like i would get into arguments with
people like
show me prove it to me you know what i
mean like because they couldn't prove it
you know what i mean and so then they
couldn't prove it
so they're like why don't you like the
lord inhale this carbon dioxide or
monoxide see how long it lasts that's
natural
like like so like with ayahuasca
like when you take it there's no
physical
like it doesn't harm your body in any
way and it doesn't like
it doesn't like in any scientifical
whatever i haven't seen anything where
it like
hurts you in any way and so that was
like what i was going off of and
i'm like so how do we know that the
profits weren't getting high
you know what i mean taking ayahuasca
and doing all these shamanistic things
and people come out of those experiences
completely changed they say my life is
forever
changed because that one time i went
there yeah but the same thing can happen
with the new age movement
yeah exactly people that have hardcore
heroin addictions
isn't that one of the ways that they use
to kind of reset them yeah
yeah like there's actual there's
actually like like cases where people
have
overcome a severe heroin addict
addiction through tripping out yeah like
going to the home team over here
and then it's all of a sudden like
pressing the reset button on your brain
or something
yeah not advocating at all yeah i'm not
advocating that at all yeah
but yeah well and and that's that's
where i was questioning on right
because i grew up and you know it was
don't eat don't drink coffee because
it's bad and it's like
why is it bad and most of the time it
was just like it's bad don't do it
and when you get raised with that
mentality you're like
and you'd see someone be like don't eat
chocolate it's bad and they're eating
chocolate you know what i mean or
they have this adult like perception
don't watch rated r movies
like i can because i'm 18. you know what
i mean but like
so everything's bad at a certain limit
and then it's okay
you know that on sin exactly and so
that's how i saw these things so now i'm
questioning everything
because when i come back it's not just
like oh which of the church says no it's
like what does the bible say you need to
prove it to me
you know so when i came back to that and
i'm just like i was asking my parents i
was frustrating them and like you know
just like i really want to know so i get
back to the states
and uh buddy comes over and he's like
hey man i got some ayahuasca do you
wanna
like you wanna get down with it and i
was like
uh okay
and so i i left the room and i went to
um to another room and i i started
praying i said lord
i really honestly want to know if you
are in the ayahuasca if you made this
for to benefit man to help us to come
closer to you through
some type of whatever in our minds show
me
i i honestly because i really believe
god
wants us to ask honestly whatever it is
i'm not saying i'm not condoning any of
this okay
not by any means but i'm saying
i asked him and i went back and i i
we drank it you know whatever and um
started waiting for the onset my friends
went out and started puking or whatever
and i for some reason i didn't puke
and uh i could feel it starting to set
in which i've never heard of
a case of anybody not puking yeah i know
these people are like i'm not gonna
yeah it happens every time well
[Laughter]
went back to the same room and i started
asking the lord i'm like lord if you're
in it like
make it known to me like make it very
clear speak to me teach me
then i went back and the night just
started progressing and getting more and
more intense
and not spiritual it was started getting
more and more demonic
and it just started getting more darker
and darker and i remember
i was like my room was like kind of like
a cabin
and like i had a loft or whatever and i
remember going
up up to the up to go to sleep and i
just remember i could not
just find peace it was just chaos and i
was just like
rolling in my bed and it was just like
getting more and more chaotic and i
could just see like
you know in the darkness like figures
moving around me and i would just
i could not find that peace and i keep
pleading with the lord
lord if you're in it please help me you
know what i mean and so when i finally
came out of it that was the last i've
ever done
like ever ever messed with it because
the lord showed me i am not
in that you know what i mean like when
he asked elijah am i in this am i in
this
i'm in this still small voice and this
is where i found god
he's in the word and so
a lot of people will say those things
but for me
i know that those things have nothing to
do with
with god you know what i mean you can
lick a toad and see things
but that doesn't make it spiritual you
know what i mean because you ask
how many people that go down the
psychedelic route
how peaceful it stayed and how clear did
it become
you know what i mean did it get better
and better as you progressed
did you find more and more understanding
about the lord
or did it get become more and more
confusion yeah i think that the
barometer really is the piece that
passes all understanding like
like the closer that you draw to to god
you know there there's something
different about that
and and like you said man the proof is
in the pudding you start going and
really assessing your life is it falling
apart
are things just you know like chaotic
around you
that's a telltale sign right there yeah
whether or not god's in something
you were honestly and genuinely putting
god to the test with this thing and i
think that's why
you didn't have an experience where you
saw a white light and you felt
love and all that because people have
that and that's a deception god
prevented
you from seeing that and instead you saw
the black dark figures in the chaos
god was showing you clearly i'm not in
this
like that's just like telling me if
you're actually sincere that
you want to get close to god if you ask
him he will
actually show you a really clear sign we
just have to ask
yes i think it's a challenge to anybody
i mean if you are seriously
truth seeking and and opening your heart
to god no matter how
deep you got yourself into sin if you
ask
god reveal yourself to me he is not
going to ignore you
i mean his desire is to save you to the
utmost and he will not leave you alone
in fact you will start to see some
miraculous things happen so i think it's
a
it's a challenge to anybody who's in
that space
you know for sure about i really want to
make it clear to like whoever's watching
like it but if you take this
as a you're going to go test god
and you and you know what you're doing
is wrong
god you god cannot protect you in that
stance
you're putting your hands in the devils
and
with if you're not sincere in what
you're doing you
you're tempting god yeah we're warning
you right now do not do that good point
and i think that
is because the devil's also watching us
and so he knows
wow this person right here is truth
seeking and you step on his ground he's
going to be like
he's mine i better take him now while i
have the chance
so you're actually inviting i think even
worse of a demonic
experience by by allowing that you know
sort of testing ground yeah it's way
better to not like
you know test it just to see if it's
real yeah yeah yeah yeah
i guess i was gonna go there uh next
cause
i know you're you're talking about you
know you ask god about this substance
and
you know you know for you somebody else
could have a very different experience
yeah still doesn't make it right right
and
i think the important thing for
whoever's watching to know is
god doesn't need to prove himself
through that substance god can prove
himself anyway
yeah and it's better
to just ask god you know put god to the
test
anyway without anything you know that to
me is an
even even greater test like look you get
nothing god
reveal yourself you know make yourself
known
um because the other things you know
especially if you're one of these people
like you had a bad experience somebody
had a good experience they're more
likely to trust it
and say that god is in it and it may not
be you know
it's not but because of their experience
it changes their you know perception
about it so you got to be careful about
that
yeah satan loves to mess with our senses
because most of the time we believe
our senses no matter what the book says
yeah right
so i i really appreciate you being
transparent and sharing that story with
us now i want to see like
where does god have you right now
because this is really interesting when
you pull up here this huge beast and i'm
like curious to know like
how you got to this point yeah i i used
to work at an
embroidery shop and i i
i prayed to the lord and i every day i
would walk out of that embroidery shop
and go stand by this pond
on my breaks and pray lord i want to
work for you
and i just i kept praying and praying
and praying it
and i i quit working there and i started
doing freelance
like artwork or whatever and you
specialize in
uh sorry what do you specialize in oh
i'd paint windows you know like the
window painter guys and i would do
like t-shirts i would like send out like
artwork to
screen printers and they would ship them
in and then
um just like anything digital whatever
anyone needed type of thing
mural stuff um but i
i started working on a testimony video
and a few other videos because i just
felt like i needed
i needed to get out and tell you know
what i mean like
i i just wanted to work for the lord in
some way you know what i mean i'm like i
have a camera
i have a computer let's just start you
know let's
put something together that's awesome
hey my name is jason shuchuk
and each one of us has a story and this
is part of my story
done in symbolism and after this video
i'll explain all the symbols
[Music]
enjoy
god opened the doors for me to work at a
school for troubled youth
and that just like opened my mind like
my just blew my mind seeing these kids
like just like i used to be
and like showing like my testimony at
that school
and seeing how it like it reached a lot
of the kids there because
a lot of them were into drugs a lot of
them were into like craziness and just
opened the doors for me to be able to
talk to them
and so from there god moved me um
i moved up to the northeastern
washington and uh i lived
uh like out off grid with my dad and i
would still do ministry stuff
up there i would do uh like i was tiny
youtube channel and i just put videos
out there
i didn't care if it reached one person i
just i won i wanted to to
work for the lord and then um
one day i get a call from uh don frost
and uh he said uh what are you doing how
do you know who you were
i guess there was a guy in walla walla
that
i used to talk to he worked for blue
mountain television
and i guess they knew each other and he
don was looking for a video editor
and he recomm like recommended me to him
so sent me a call i went started working
with don
and did some video editing for him and
he kept telling me about this project
that they were going to do
and i didn't i didn't care much about it
i was just like yeah that's interesting
because like you talk about doing a
great big daniel too and carving it and
all this stuff and i'm like well i'm not
really a carver
and so i don't like i do video stuff and
um
then i was traveling with him and he's
like he's like hey
uh we should go look for like um
someone like chainsaw carvers and like
learn about this stuff or whatever i'm
like all right so i was with them
and we stopped at this school that did
um
chainsaw carving and they like they they
teach you for like three days or
whatever
so he got a group of people to come out
there and he's like we're gonna we're
gonna learn to do this or whatever
okay don and so we're out doing the
changes you went to the school yeah i
went to the school took the three days
and i actually like fell in love with
chainsaw carving
and so like it was really interesting to
me but um
we they started working on the project
but i felt this calling to go to canada
some of my friends were in trouble so i
needed to go help them
but while i was gone they started
working on the daniel too
and um which is this image yeah right
there
and uh i came i came back from helping
and i i call up dawn see how the
project's going
and he says well not good man um our our
carver
his um his parents are actually
um going to pass away soon they're not
doing too well so he has to go down to
florida
and i just kind of jokingly said well if
you if you need someone like i'm more
than willing to
and i totally was just joking because i
didn't like
and he's like well we prayed about it
and we asked the lord if if there's
anyone that he would open the doors and
for you to say that you're
like i'm just like oh shoot and i was
just like okay lord
and so uh i was i went over there and i
started
working and like i'm dead serious like
i was scared out of my mind like i've
only like
from carving with him i only had done a
few carvings
at school yeah like practice at the
school or whatever they're just teaching
you cutouts and stuff
and then i did like a small a smaller
daniel two
like just me and my dad tooling around
and then like
so when i got there to that thing and
you're just standing looking at this
tree you're just like
and i remember looking at it and i'm
like i felt like david coming against
the light like this thing was so big
and i just i i cried multiple times just
saying lord if you
if you want me to do this like i need
your help i cannot
like i know physically i don't have
the ability like and the other carver
had gotten quite a bit like
off of it already so he does a lot of
the cutouts
and i just remember like working on
every day just pleading with the lord to
help me to help me and it really
increased my faith
just like going out there and just like
keep on working on it
i think that's why you were the exact
right person to work on that
because i think most often god uses
people that are
totally unequipped should not be there
freaked out of their mind to actually
work on that thing why because you have
to depend on him
and when you depend on him he can
actually equip you
properly to do the job oftentimes we get
in god's way
all right you said you got it i'm gonna
let you do it but if you're like lord i
need you
lord you gotta do it yeah man that's
amazing
yeah so we got to work on that project
and finish it up
and um actually when we're
i kept saying we need to get a a rock
like you can't have the daniel 2 without
the rock right you got to have this rock
coming at it
and they're saying well you know we've
spent all the money if you're going
to if you want to do a rock you got to
do it on your own so i kept praying i
was like lord we need a rock we need a
rock
and this guy one day i was helping
someone move or i can't remember what it
was
from the from the church in the area
says to me he's like he's like
so have you guys thought about doing a
rock i'm like dude i've been praying
about it and he goes he goes well
let me tell you i have an insulation
um company like a foam insulation and we
did
um the different like uh
artwork for this silverwood it's kind of
like a
like theme park type of thing he goes we
did all the foam for that and we worked
with
artists so have you ever thought about
doing that out of foam i'm like
what oh man that would be awesome and he
goes
look come to my shop i'll give you all
the foam you need and everything i'm
like
are you serious the total answer to
prayer uh we were able to make a rock
have it there for like the opening when
when it came and i was just like thank
you lord and afterwards like he was so
excited about the rock
he comes up to me says look if you
if you want to keep making something or
if you want to do more
i'll i'll help you build the the the
next
like a beast or whatever you want and i
was just like whoa lord so
um with that in mind it didn't it didn't
work out that he
he did it but it was always in my mind i
started like 3d like
making one on like on blender and stuff
and like creating it
and um and i just had in my mind we need
to make
uh we need to make this and i actually
ran into this dude which is a chainsaw
car
from north um north dakota
i don't feel like that's a real common
job like you just have to run into a
chase no it's all right
i've never even met a chainsaw car well
this is what it's come down to i truly
believe
you know like if we put our our life in
god's hands
nothing is coincidence and nothing
everything is set up
and uh this dude his name's tyler dick i
mean
like good dude man like and uh
we met up at this church and he and um
god opened the doors for me and his
family to be able to live
together on the same property and he was
just like and and we started carving
together we did
um that other beast the big green one
and uh fourth beast of daniel yeah and
we
we carved that together that was an
adventure man and so that's where we
learned
you know carving foam really like
because the the rock wasn't as
dynamic as like this beast was yeah so
that's where we learned that
and um now tyler has that he's going
around the states with it
him and his family um and
uh and then we god opened the doors for
us to be
to build this one so now we're traveling
the country
so you and your family are driving
around with the beast of revelation
tyler and his family are driving around
with the fourth beast yeah daniel
and and then this huge image is supposed
to be traveling as well that's pretty
cool man like yeah what a way to witness
to people
it's different what are people's
responses when you're driving around
with this thing
well why don't we go check it out and
see how people respond dude you want to
take it to walmart
let's go ahead and see this
is that the beast of revelation
[Music]
how much is
i'm really off
[Laughter]
i mean what a fantastic ministry you
know what i mean like what a great way
because we're visual we're all visual
and and i mean it's why i think
disney theme parks are so big you know
people like to go there and see their
thing out and all this bigness
and and here is a way for us to see the
bible in in
in a physical tangible way we can walk
around it and and be like you know yeah
why does
what's each one of these horns on his
head what's the skulls on the side of
this thing
you know you have people who are so into
comics sci-fi zombies
monsters and they look to christianity
or the bible like oh that's so boring
really yeah we had that first
yeah comic book ripped off revelations
right that's right yeah
yeah so speaking of like a theme park or
something you actually have an idea a
concept
what's your idea for what you would like
to do with these things
oh man i i don't know it's just the
dream in it i mean i always thought that
would be sweet and your dreams to god
i don't know i just always thought it'd
be awesome to be able to
um to have an area where someone can
literally walk through revelation or
daniel
or whatever it is where they're they're
walking through
each scene you know as and you can hear
it over
the speakers or whatever as like a
narrator's
narrator is narrating the whole book
just straight from the bible it's just
like so the person just seeing the bible
and living color you know
and experiencing it because i tell you
like
to have a kid walk through that they
will never forget it you know what i
mean and they can't walk out of there
and be like the bible's boring
you know what i mean like there's no way
have you guys been to the bible museum
in d.c
she's talking about that so cool the
thing is they use like um images on the
wall like projections and
paintings and things like that i think
they have a few sculptures but i think
even bringing it to life even more and
having something tangible like in front
of them
yeah fantastic like that even that's
really unique oh yeah i mean you can
you could do so much i mean with
nowadays with like
with projectors and smoke and lighting
and
sounds blowing for the win cool
yeah i mean this is this is just yet
another reason
where god has placed inside of each and
every one of us a a sort of creative
desire
i mean your creativity may be with
numbers i don't know you may be good at
statistics or something like that right
and you may like all of a sudden like i
have a i have a cousin that's actually
brilliant um and and and he actually
is so good with numbers whatever he's
touched
he's thrived with can you imagine if
that person was like
involved in ministry yeah you know i
mean like like each one of us has this
talent and it's really just
opening ourselves up to god and saying
god how can i use this for you
and look at the way that god opened up
doors and just directed your past
now you're in this hairball drive across
the country with a beast in the back of
your car
oh man satan would have loved your
talent be like the most demonic comics
you know
and and you're using your talent for god
just like with me i used to do
music videos and t-shirts that were just
really
worldly and now i get to use that same
video editing
skill and the t-shirts and all that
stuff and it's just awesome to be able
to use
what god gave you it's not like you have
to be like well i really love this thing
but i guess i'm going to be a preacher
no god can use that thing that he gave
you
for him oh yeah and that's something i
you know i want to tell people is that
god made you personally you know and he
made you
so unique and the more you get to know
him the more you'll get to understand
who
he truly meant you to be you know what i
mean he gave you gifts and talents and
skills
and he will show you how to use them
correctly
and whatever your skill set
whatever it is if it's cooking knitting
whatever it is
give it to the lord and and i i hold on
i'm pretty sure it's psalms 1
that it's it in there if you read it
you'll see that it says
those who keep the commandments whatever
they put their hands to do will prosper
and i truly hold on to that because he
will take whatever you're doing and
bless it
you know i remember at the very
beginning of getting into
trying to work for the lord i had no
clue what i was doing i just was like i
need to make a video
and i just like i i just want to send it
out just on facebook just tell
tell people about the lord you know and
that's all it was and it just kept
growing and growing whatever it is just
put your foot forward and god will bless
it keep going
that's right you don't need tony robbins
you don't need any of those like
self-help
people you just need to follow the
commandments of god and he will bless
you
and there's one more thing don't be
scared of the means
don't be scared my family and i and i've
watched it for
for tyler and his family as well i've
watched god provide
for our families like no tomorrow and
and i mean remember seek first the
kingdom and all these things will be
added unto you
your food your drink and your clothing
we keep going and god
keeps opening the door for us to be okay
because we don't have jobs
we don't have i mean we have jobs and
they're very high up there i mean in
heaven
but they're not what people think and
people get really like well how are you
how are you doing that how can you do
that it doesn't matter with god you just
go forward and he'll take care of you
that's right that's right we have a
t-shirt for that yeah
yeah man that's just amazing you know
powerful testimony
um just great to see that yeah god made
us personal he gave
us talents we should be using our
talents for god and stepping out in
faith like you
and your friend and and just trusting
that god will provide for all those
things
and if you're out there and you have a
awesome talent i just want to encourage
you to use that talent like he said
it could be as simple as just recording
your testimony and putting on youtube
that's why i tell everybody
we might not all be preachers but we all
have a testimony and we all have cameras
and you have no clue how impactful that
your story could be revelation says that
they overcame by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of their testimony
just sit in front of your camera share
your testimony upload it to youtube
and you have no idea you'll run into
somebody in the kingdom that would be
like
i ran across your video that's why i'm
here like i just
can't wait to spend eternity just
hearing all the stories of how
god reached and used each and every one
of us who were willing
and that's the thing we have to be
willing just lay it all down and let god
use you thank you so much for joining us
if you like this video click like don't
forget to subscribe and share this with
all your friends
and check out some more of our videos
we'll see you next week god bless you
[Music]
guys
you